l'actualité aujourd'hui c'est aussi la
reconstitution de la mort du petit
grégory retrouvé souvenez vous noyer il
ya trois ans dans la vologne dans le
département des vosges c'était la
première journée de la reconstitution
dans la pluie le froid avec le nouveau
juge d'instruction chargés de la faire
monsieur maurice simon il veut savoir
monsieur simon si christine villemin a
eu le temps d'accomplir ce geste
terrible sur place en quête de roland
sicard trois ans presque jour pour jour
après la mort du petit grégory
les principaux protagonistes du drame se
sont retrouvés une nouvelle fois à
lépanges sur vologne
jean marie villemin d'abord arrivée de
la maison d'arrêt de saverne où il est
détenu depuis l'assassinât de bernard
laroche et sivignon ensuite qu'il
n'était pas revenu sur place depuis
plusieurs mois à 14h30 le juge maurice
sinon qu'est maintenant le dossier en
main arrivé à la mairie de lépante la
grande reconstitution que le magistrat
avait organisé pouvait commencer
une reconstitution qui pourrait apporter
des éléments décisifs
et
ce sommes réclamées depuis 18 mois nous
sommes dans cette affaire ne l'obtenons
français aujourd'hui
pendant tout l'après midi christine
villemin a refusé de se prêter à la
reconstitution le juge simon voulait
établir si la jeune femme a eu le temps
dans le cas où elle serait coupable de
commettre le crime
dans cette hypothèse christine villemin
après avoir quitté son travail
ce serait d'abord rendu à la poste de
lépanges pour envoyer la lettre
revendiquant l'assassinât
elle serait ensuite allé chercher
grégory chez sa nourrice avant de se
diriger vers la vologne
là où l'enfant a été noyée sous le
regard de jean marie villemin
le juge simon apprenons mettrait tous
les trajets il s'est sans doute ce soir
si l'hypothèse de la culpabilité de
christine villemin est toujours
envisageable
demain il entendra les principaux
témoins avec l'espoir d'éclaircir trois
ans après les faits le mystère de la
mort des petits oiseaux